vamos directo a Lima donde la noticia es
la pregunta de extradición del
expresidente peruano Alejandro Toledo un
juez de San Francisco en Estados Unidos
le ordenó al antiguo mandatario que se
entregue a la policía a más tardar el
viernes las autoridades estadounidenses
lo enviarían de regreso a Perú donde la
fiscalía lo acusa de aceptar
multimillonarios sobornos por parte de
la gigantesca constructora odebrecht
conectamos a esta hora Con nuestro
corresponsal en la capital peruana
Francisco Zacarías Francisco Buenas
noches para usted y cuéntenos qué
procedimiento seguirán las autoridades
estadounidenses para detener a Alejandro
Toledo
Buenas noches el juez Thomas hitson
atendiendo una solicitud de la fiscalía
general de los Estados Unidos le ha
ordenado al expresidente peruano
Alejandro Toledo entregarse a los
agentes federales en la sede de la corte
del distrito Norte de California este
viernes 21 seguidamente Toledo será
trasladado a una prisión del Condado de
San Mateo a sus 77 años el ex mandatario
peruano aguardará en esta cárcel su
entrega a los agentes peruanos mientras
transcurre los trámites de la
extradición el gobierno estadounidense
espera la llegada de los funcionarios
peruanos pero todavía no hay fecha para
que esto ocurra lo que sí se conoce Es
que la justicia norteamericana ya no
quiere ser sorprendida tanto por los
recursos legales que están presentando
Alejandro Toledo y sus abogados tratando
de evitar su extradición a Perú y para
Que responda a la en un caso de
corrupción donde la fiscalía acusa al
expresidente de Toledo de haber recibido
un soborno de 35 millones de dólares que
fue entregado por la empresa odebrecht
para la construcción de la carretera
interoceánica entre Perú y Brasil
Francisco y es que como usted lo
mencionó la defensa de Alejandro Toledo
ha presentado múltiples recursos para
evitar que la justicia estadounidense lo
extradite una extradición que en
principio había sido avalada hace unas
semanas ahora este proceso se está
acelerando qué reacciones ha habido en
Perú
la primera reacción ha sido de Roberto
su abogado de Alejandro Toledo en este
país quien ha señalado que el ex
gobernante padece de cáncer que una
enfermedad que ha señalado que lo tiene
hace varios meses atrás y ha dicho que
la extradición podría empeorar su estado
de salud el defensor también ha señalado
que Toledo desconfía de la justicia
peruana entre tanto ex colaboradores y
hasta opositores a Toledo afirman que el
ex mandatario habría cometido diversos
delitos y ya es hora de que Alejandro
Toledo se somete a la justicia peruana
por su parte Javier Arévalo presidente
del poder judicial de este país ha
firmado que Alejandro Toledo tiene la
garantía de llevarse un proceso debido y
que también va a tener acceso a la
legítima defensa la justicia peruana le
ha iniciado Alejandro Toledo un juicio
por corrupción y tiene previsto
emprender otro por lavado de activos
algunos analistas políticos están
señalando que varios funcionarios y
empresarios no les conviene la
extradición de Alejandro Toledo porque
se cree que Toledo podría delatar a sus
Cómplices con tal de obtener beneficios
de la justicia que le podrían reducir
cualquier tipo de condena por los
delitos que se le está procesando